Hi, everyone.
This is Yihue Xie, sorry
that I can't attend
the RStudio conference
in person this year,
but I guess you
won't miss anything
from this talk with my absence.
Well, if you really
miss my face,
you can simply
Google for my picture
and stare at it for 20
minutes along with this talk.
So there are people
who are really
familiar with my talk
and my previous talks
and work on the
so-called down packages.
They are so familiar that
every time they meet me they
don't greet me with usual.
What's up?
Instead, they say what's down?
Well, this time, I'm
not going to talk
about any down packages.
I won't let you down as usual.
So what's down?
Nothing is down.
What's up?
Quarto is up.
So most down packages
have had or will
have equivalents
in Quarto, which
you might have heard for several
times at this conference.
And I need to I probably should
clarify that the down packages
won't be down anytime soon.
We will continue
to maintain them.
So why am I talking
about knitr today?
Because the knitr package
is a common cornerstone
of Quarto and R markdown,
so both of them
are built on top of knitr.
So you can apply what
you have learned today
about knitr in this
talk to both Quarto
and R Markdown documents.
So knitr has existed
for a little over 10 years.
So the development
started in 2011
and I made the first CRAN
release in January 2012.
Over these years I have made
more than 50 CRAN releases
and there have been more
than two 5,000 questions
on Stack Overflow and more
than 2000 GitHub issues
and pull requests.
I would also like to thank
all the knitr contributors
and there are more
than one hundred of them.
Since the pandemic I have
almost lost track of time.
So basically, I want
to look back and see
what I have done in
the past two years,
whether I have done
anything meaningful.
So as I said, knitr
is over 10 years old,
so it has become quite mature
and probably inevitably boring
as time goes by.
You know, when things
become mature they often
become boring to just
like adults, you know,
kids are much more fun.
Yeah, for software,
being mature is not bad.
It's actually a good
thing. In this talk.
I'm not I'm not going
to, I'm not going
to talk about any, like,
totally exciting new features
because there are not any huge
new features in recent years
in, in the development
of knitr.
But I would like to highlight
a few little things.
So for a full list of
changes and new features,
you can check out the release
notes of knitr later.
So the first thing
I want to highlight
is that now you have a new
way to write chunk options.
Previously, you must
write all chunk options
on one line in the chunk
header, but now you
can write them on multiple
lines as special comments
in the beginning of
the chunk of body.
So this special comment
start with the hash character
followed by the pipe character.
I'm not sure how would you
pronounce this combination?
Maybe hash pipe?
I remember someone mentioned
me that hash pipe was
a funny coincidence.
Since I'm not a native
English speaker,
I had no idea what hash pipe
means, so I googled for that
and I regret it. Anyway,
hash pipe comments.
You can use that to
write chunk options.
So as I said
previously, you have
to force all the chunk options
onto a single line, which
is sometimes very awkward.
If you have many, many chunk
options for a single chunk,
there will be an awkward
horizontal scroll bar.
But now you can write all of
your chunk options can write
With your chunk body.
You can put them
inside the chunk
after the special comments.
And you can also hard wrap
all these lines freely.
You can write them on
any number of lines.
So, for example, you can put
one chunk option on one line
or you can break a single
chunk option in the middle.
You can wrap them
in any way you like,
and alternatively, you can also
use the YAML syntax to provide
your chunk options.
So previously I'm
showing the old syntax
of comma separated chunk options
of the form option equals value
and separated by commas.
If you're familiar
with yaml, that syntax
will be option colon
followed by value
and you have to write
one option per line
For Quarto in RStudio
or VS Code users.
I strongly recommend that
you use the YAML syntax
because the editors,
RStudio and VS Code.
They have better support
for the YAML options.
For example, they can help you
out complete the option names.
They can validate the
values of your options.
And second, the
YAML syntax works
for other engines in Quarto
as well, such as Jupyter.
So if you want to
convert from a convert
the old syntax to the new
syntax, there is a function
and convert chunk
header in knitr.
So you can use that
function to convert
your old Markdown documents to
using the new syntax for chunk
options.
But this requires a very
recent version of knitr.
And the second thing
I want to talk about
is how to reuse chunk, both
chunk options and chunk content
from other code chunks.
So previously there
existed several ways
to reuse the content
of a code chunk,
for example, through
the ref.label option.
So suppose you have one code
chunk with the label chunk A
and then you can write another
code chunk with label chunk B,
but set the chunk option ref.label
equals chunk A
ref.label equals chunk A
That means I want to copy
the chunk content of chunk
A into chunk B. So now although you
see the chunk B is empty here,
but when you execute this
document chunk B will
have the same
content as chunk A.
You can learn more about
reusing the chunk content
in the R Markdown cookbook.
So now in addition to reusing
the content of code chunks,
you can also reuse chunk
options from other code chunks.
And this can be done through
the chunk option ops dot label.
So for example, you
have chunk A here
and you have set a couple
of chunk options on chunk A
and if you want to use the
same chunk options in chunk B,
then you simply need, you
simply can set opts.label
equals chunk A.
So instead of repeating all
the chunk options from chunk A,
you simply set a single option.
opts.label equals
chunk A and then chunk B
will use the same chunk
options as chunk A.
Then if you want to reuse both
chunk options and the content
from other code chunks, you can
set the chunk option ref.label
to the label of
other code chunks
and then wrap the
labels in the function I.
For example, here I have chunk
A which has a few chunk options
and then it also has
some chunk content.
And then in chunk B
I said ref.label equals
I, chunk A that means I want to
use both the content of chunk A
and the chunk
options of chunk A.
So in that way you don't have
to repeat everything from chunk A.
You simply set a single
option and knitr will
copy everything to the
next to chunk B
So I also want to
share two quick tips.
First, the chunk options
ref.label and opts.label,
can take a
vector of chunk labels.
That means you can reuse
multiple code chunks instead
of a single one. Second,
you can provide further
low code chunk options.
If you, if a code chunk has
some local chunk options,
they will overwrite the reused
options of the same names.
So in this example,
chunk B is basically
reusing both chunk options and
the chunk content of chunk A,
but it has set a low code.
chunk option dev equals png.
So since we have
borrowed all the chunk
options from chunk A which
includes the chunk option
dev equals SVG.
So now chunk B since chunk
B has a local chunk option
dev=png, this
equals png will override
the dev equals png from chunk a.
So basically local chunk options
will have higher priorities
if you reuse chunk options
from other code chunks.
Third thing I want to mention
is some of the new chunk
options in knitr.
In recent years we have
added a few of them.
But today I'm just going
to mention one of them
here, which is the file option.
So sometimes you may
want to develop code
in an external script and
include it in code chunk.
Previously what you could do is
to use the chunk option code.
So for example, here I'm
using the chunk option
code that takes the value
from red lines script.R
So that basically means I want
to read an external script
and pass the content
of that script
to the code option
and then knitr knows
I will use the
content of that script
as the content of this code.
chunk.
That's the previous way of
including external scripts
into a code chunk.
Now this can be simplified
to the chunk option file.
So you can set file.
You cause a file path,
for example, script.R.
so basically that's
equivalent to using code
equals read lines.
Scripts are before and
this file option also
supports a vector of file paths.
For example, you can pass two
scripts to the file option
and the file option
will read both of them
into the code chunk.
The fourth thing I
want to highlight
is some new engines in knitr.
The first one is comment engine.
So you can use
the comment engine
to comment out any content.
And the content can contain
basically anything, including
code chunks or
include or inline R
expressions or other
paragraphs or anything.
So basically there's one rule
that you have to remember.
If the comment contains
three back ticks and then
for the comment engine, you
have to start with four backtics.
So basically the rule is
that if your comment contains
any tactics, then
the comment engine
needs to start with
m plus 1 tactics.
So, if the content
is commented out,
it will not be
included in the output.
And the second engine
is the verbatim engine.
And this can be very
useful when you want
to write tutorials on R Markdown.
So and, and you may want to
display some content verbatim,
especially the code chunks.
When you want to display
a code chunk verbatim,
you can use the verbatim engine
and the rule is the same.
So for example, here I'm
including a code chunk
with three back tics and
then the verbatim engine
needs to start with four
back tics. For the verbatim engine,
depending on the
content of, depending
on the language of the
content, you can, you
can set a syntax highlighting
language through the chunk
option lang.
So for example here I'm
using lang equals Markdown.
That means the verbatim
content here is Markdown code.
But this lang
option is optional,
so it depends on
whether you want
to syntax highlighting
in your output
for the verbatim content.
Previously I have introduced
some old, ugly hacks
on how to show content
verbatim, and now you
can forget all of them.
And here I just.
Yeah, I don't want to
explain this anymore.
It's just too ugly.
Use the verbatim
engine and forget
about the old, ugly hacks.
The third engine that I want
to show is the embed engine.
So you can use this.
You can use the embed engine
to embed external files,
text files.
Actually, you can embed
external text files
and display their
content verbatim.
So this is similar to
the verbatim engine,
but you can use the file
option to embed external files
so you don't have to write
the content in the chunk body.
You just appoint the file
option to some file paths.
And alternatively, you
can write file paths
in the chunk body
of the embed engine.
For example, you can write
quote, food.R, quote bar.R. .
Ah, so the second way
has a tiny advantage.
That is if you write
in the chunk body,
if you write to the file paths
in the chunk body, your editor,
for example, RStudio may be able
to autocomplete the file paths.
The last engine that I want to
show here is the exec engine.
So this engine allows you to
execute an arbitrary system
command on a file that contains
the content of the chunk
so that command can be specified
through the chunk option
command.
So, for example, I have
an exec engine here
and I'm using the
command equals bash.
That means I want to run the
command bash on the command
that has specified.
In the chunk body.
So basically when knitr
sees an exact chunk,
it will write the
chunk body into a file
and execute a
command on that file.
So for this patch
example, actually, you
don't have to use
the exact engine.
You can simply use the
existing bash engine in knitr.
So these two code chunks
are pretty much equivalent.
There have existed a lot
of command based engines
in knitr, for example, arc
or go or Perl or Z Shell.
And from now on,
we no longer need
to add a new engine for
every single command.
You can basically use the exact
engine to execute any command.
And by the way, the exact
engine is also extensible.
So you can, if you're interested
in go back and check out
the examples, the example on
the link through the link here.
So for those who are
curious about how
the exact engine works,
so basically knitr
will execute a command
of the form command args one,
args two, sorry, command args one, args two
where
args is a file path.
And this file
contains the content
of the code chunk and
args one and args
two are optional command
line arguments that you
may specify through the chunk
option engine.ops.
So here I have an example that
executes the grep command.
With a few command
line arguments I
and which means case
insensitive matching
and then the pattern is he
and I want to execute grep
on the four lines of
text here so he will
if we match each E in
case in sensitivity
it will match the first line
hellos in the third line
since it has the
which contains H E.
And just a quick recap.
We have talked about four
things in today's talk.
First thing is that you can use
hash pipe comments in the chunk
body to write chunk options.
Then you can use opts.label
and ref.label options
to re-use both chunk
options and content.
And third, you can
use the file option
to read external files
as the chunk content.
And last, we have introduced
a few new engines in knitr.
So that's all I
have for you today.
Thank you very much
and happy meeting.